je rentre à demain matin où tu vois je
dors chez suzy ce soir
c'est nouveau la fiche dans le journal
ils appellent l'attrapeur j'aime pas que
tu l'appelles comme ça tu crois quand
même parce que les autres raconte parce
qu'ils peuvent attendre il enlève pas
vraiment ce qu'ils sont
quel ordre de wii super formidable je
vous ai dis regarde moi ça
tu peux me donner mon chapeau
merci jeunes âmes je suis magicien
amateurs
vous avez des ballons noirs là bas si tu
veux je te fais un tour de magie
j'ai quelque chose à vous annoncer l'un
de nos élèves green et blake a été
kidnappé et si je pouvais aider la
police à retrouver finesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils marchent pas
il marchait déjà pas quand j'étais petit
je l aurais je vous ai corps ferez le
visage celui ci
j'ai rêvé de lui et ce qui se passait
dans ton rêve il se faisait enlever un
homme avec des ballons noirs la police
n'a jamais révélé ce détail
e
halo ne raccroche pas sais qui
tu nous connais tous
tu vas faire tes rbc
s'il vous plaît faites que m a dit tu
regardes le maire en face de toi j'ai
arraché un câble sur toute la longueur
ya un cap makoun sur la porte d'entrée
tu te souviens du code
jeu les graver sur le mur s'est fait mal
tout
comme la porte la grille je reconnais
qu'il avait vu plusieurs fois en règle
m
tu vas te servir d'une arme je lève le
combiné un pas en arrière et tu feras
tu vois ce que tu m'as fait taire et
laisser vous rappelle que je t'avais dit
qu'à un moment il faudrait que
j'apprenne à me défendre ces mamans
c'est ma chance
il pensait même pas
vous faire perdre la tête
[Musique]
je
les accompagne partout vision
[Musique]
partout
c'est
comment va le fruit de nos amours
c'est un menteur texte pas les parents
qui nous sommes et leurs collègues
trois cents personnes plus ou moins
c'est ça
[Musique]
ça me prend parfois quand je suis seul
homme du bonheur
je pousse à l'extrême inverse sur craig
ce
[Musique]
n'est pas maladroit
ni plus ni moins que la plupart des gens
c'est les grands sont tous un peu malade
je retiens des épisodes et un beau deux
jours à tuer de protéger davantage
[Musique]
non branche
on en sorte que la retiennent tout
[Musique]
quand la qualité des banalités
rendez vous de l'histoire
m
[Musique]
ça fait dix ans que vous vous droguer
pourquoi avoir commencé
[Musique]
moi ces gouttes les toxicomanes ça nous
permettrait de recommencer à zéro
la barre toi
pas facile de demander de l'aide c'est
pour ça que la plus grande satisfaction
de ma vie de vous aider à changer la
france
on est une grande famille vous emballez
pas trop je vais vous avouer un petit
secret
depuis 2008 toutes les assurances santé
de couvrir les traitements des troubles
liés à la toxicomanie dans l'industrie
de la santé on appelle ça la ruée vers
l'or
je veux plus de cette vie de merde
j'aimerais bien faire ce boulot - utah
bienvenue dans l'équipe
bonjour vous êtes au centre de
désintoxication
c'est quoi ça c'est le rêve américain
dont kim en désintox tu touches heures
pourcentage et tu leur enfilent un peu
et c'est tout ça s'appelle le
capitalisme
[Musique]
mais bon j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
compter de l'argent en faisant une tête
d'arabe
il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui
arrivent à faire quelque chose de leur
vie qu'est ce qui se passe cette jolie
détente one sessad de faire confiance
[Musique]
j'ai obtenu une chambre pour votre fils
d'ornano cendres il vient de se faire
9000 $ en trois minutes dieu est grand
[Musique]
je sens que nous allons passer une
journée magnifique
[Musique]
portez pas gâteux
salut que les jeunes cerveaux sont des
éponges nous nous contentons de les
essorer
[Musique]
nous avons de la visite elle nous voilà
vous croyez
ces jeunes filles n'avaient aucun
respect pour les règles
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression de ne plus être moi
même
[Musique]
elle fait confiance à personne
c'est ce qu'on aime ou dit
mais pas modique on est différente
[Musique]
nous allons devenir les meilleurs amis
du monde génial
de l'autre côté
les gars y'a pas de réseau
[Musique]
heureux de vous accueillir dans notre
nouveau centre de jeunes et de détox ou
la vache est un fondu comme beurre au
soleil je leur dit combien on peut
s'embrasser avant de passer à la pesée
jettera que je rapporte inquiète les
gros c'est pas ce qui manque
du vomi ça va nettoyer mais un test de
l'eau de l'aquarium là je suis là pour
faire un jeu préféré me taper un jeune
de 25 ans
on est là pour passer du bon temps
ensemble nom n'est pas maigrir si je
veux passer du bon temps je me fais un
plateau de fromages on peut vivre sans a
toujours dans un rapport de séduction
quand même avec grave à l'empereur
akihito a d'ores et déjà cette cure à
quoi ça sert d'être mince ça va pas
empêcher carlos de me quitter danton
cannes le problème c'est peut-être pas
le poids
carlos m'a quittée pour un homme et si
je veux le récupérer pour que je
redevienne grosse saucisse j'arrive à
l'aller 2 est ce que tu crois que ça
peut redémarrer un carlos quand tu as
fait ton coming out c'est très rare que
tu fasses ton coming back
j'ai une question à poser
vous étés les hollies
maigrir il faut la volonté moi la seule
fois je comprends le mot volonté c'est
dans la phrase plus franche comté en
fait il faut enlever ses complexes avant
d'enlever ses culottes
la durée
ces éléments ce qui sont vouloir non ok
là merkel elle dirige l'allemagne et la
visage qui tombe oh la la c'est
magnifique c'est des framboises y voit
si tu fumes les feuilles peut-être que
tu verras des framboises et
à
accompli
ouais deux originaux là j'ai bien pris
mon pouce me piquaient d'y
garer prouver
via un tissu